every one of em Craig I am the CTO and
co-founder of my hat for a data science
company that helps other companies
deploy the Ryoka models and we also have
an IDE called review on came out today
and you haven't already get their job
we've got a lot of members for your team
here today so quick agenda here I'm
going to be bouncing around with a lot
of demos for this presentation so I'll
talk a little bit about the drug that
I'm using
I'll show you a quick little example of
how I actually fly it from Python and
then they'll go into some of the
computer vision the diffusion for
actually automating the flight control
of the drone it's a really simple
algorithm object color detection and
then lastly I will put the actual
computer vision and the autonomous miss
of the drone together with the automated
deflate and if all goes according to
plan
Geron will fall along that red cloth by
the end of this presentation so first
off the actual drone it's a parrot AR -
it's in the tourist section of
amazon.com and it is very much exploited
it costs about $200 and get it shipped
in one day got a camera on the front up
here and on the bottom a whole lot of
sensors and you don't have to be a
hardware expert or a robotics expert
expert to understand it so without
further ado I think we should just get
down to business and so I am gonna be
using
let's see dragon over here
all right so I'm using rodeo for my
development environment here a little
smushed up on the screen but that's
alright
I've actually what's going to happen is
I've wrapped a really simple Python
class that can interact with the API for
the actual drone and what I'm going to
do is I'll load in my API here I'm going
to connect to my drone really quick okay
cool
all right so all right so I'm going to
connect with my drone I've got a
connection not actually doing anything
yet so I will start by actually taking
off and so what this takeoff command is
going to do it's going to send a request
to the drone it'll tell it to takeoff
and hover so this works all right
Oh
well
luckily we can also land if you can see
it still I'm gonna calibrate it which is
gonna spin it around and get all the
sensors hooked up and accustomed to the
room and since this is going a little
right I will go ahead and land my drone
oh all right so that way I'll give it a
passing grade all right so next thing
I'm gonna do here that was a really
simple program obviously it had mixed
results but that's cool most important
part and what I think it's not the
coolest part of using this drone is the
camera so camera comes equipped with
there's a front camera down camera we're
gonna be using the front-facing camera
today and what we're gonna do is use
this red sheet over here as a sort of
Matador to get the drone to all the
paint around so what we're actually
using for this is obviously Python
scientific Python the psychic image
which is a really cool wrapper around
some of the more low-level image
recognition libraries in Python and then
OpenCV as well so the general idea here
is that we're going to be able to take a
picture with the camera on the drone
this is me in our office I'm holding a
red dustpan don't substitute for the
cloth from now and what we want to be
able to do is find using Python where
the red is in our image and then based
off of where that red is will actually
make course adjustments and flight
pattern not recommendations but
procedures for the drone so if all those
ik we're planning on something like this
where I can swing this red object
wherever I want and from the center of
the camera of the drone will be able to
now
direction it should start going so first
step we're going to do a kind of a soft
demo I'm not actually going to fly the
drone with the propellers we're going to
use sort of the six year old version of
that which I'll show you in just a
second and I will showcase my alright so
I've got a little web app rigged up here
that can look at the camera and as you
can see fly my drone around the room and
here
Daria
yeah okay
all right check one more thing here
ah here we go all right I'm not crazy
yes okay so if you look there a little
red dot that is tracking the red thing
having the cloth if I fly my coat around
world it's still going to be able to
track all right I'll get to the green
thing in a minute yeah it's fine second
well I say that now I teachers run into
the wall all right so second part of our
little drone up here we're gonna do well
facial recognition or face detection
this is actually really easy to do in
Python there is a an actual package
built into OpenCV comes with a prebuilt
model where you just load in the model
you can feed this model in images and
it'll give you those lovely little
bounding boxes of people's faces
so it's a little creepy but it's
actually pretty cool and easy to use so
for example we've got this picture of
Colin right I'm committed you're here
and he's sitting on the couch in our
office little does he know he's actually
being watched by the drone so does a
pretty good job of picking her faces and
I'll walk you through now another kind
of example here's me weirdo dust bin but
you can see that being able to pick up
my face in real time has I'm walking
around the office so another exciting
demo here I'm gonna jump back into rodeo
here actually reduce the font size I
thought I was gonna need a really big
font
all right so I'm gonna start with the so
for the face detection like I said I'm
using OpenCV for actually doing the sort
of the machine learning bit I'm using
psychic image for the kind of the the
i/o or the reading in images and
displaying them and load those in here
I'm going to use the Collin on a couch
picture example and I can display that
here since that's a little small pop
this open and I can drag over here to
there yeah so we've got Collin over
there just good I'll make this a little
bit smaller there we go I don't do cool
so for the actual algorithm I have a pre
downloaded model file it's just a big
old XML file you can download it from
open CDs website reading that in
creating my face my face cascade that is
actually going to create those bounding
boxes so I can run that here and instead
of just looking at this red numpy array
which isn't super exciting I can
actually I'll throw on another rectangle
onto this so we can see there we go we
can grab Colin's face and use the face
detection algorithm without too much
trouble so to actually give you a little
bit more exciting demo what I can do I'm
gonna
sorry it's a little distorted with the
screen size yeah that's okay all right
so what I've got here is kind of a
bigger version of that walkthrough I
just did I have a series of images that
I've saved from from one of the trial
runs I did with the drone I'm gonna loop
through all those images and then print
them back out and show you how I made
that gif that I showed you in the
presentation so I can run all these
whoops okay there we go and so what you
can see here is just kind of in real
time this is how drone sort trouble kind
of cool when I kind of block my face or
when the thing gets in the way
they're really small I put the minimum
pixel size for a basic 30 by 30 pixels
you can so the function that I'm using
for this is it's right here so I can
actually specify the minimum size for
the algorithm some other parameters
hyper parameters for tuning it as well
yeah it'll pick up multiple faces at the
same time I don't have an example of
that unfortunately but it does do that
so that's the face detection bit the
other piece that read detector the red
filter that I showed you all earlier
again same kind of deal
working with whoops I've got a sample
image loaded here which I can show you
again move the dust pan the way that
this one works is actually really simple
so it creates upper and lower bounds for
the color red so there and filtering out
anything in the image that doesn't
appear within that span so I can set
those bounds like this I can create
what's called a mask and then apply that
mask to that image that I just showed
you and then I can rerender that and
what you'll see here is that I've got
that same picture of me holding the dust
pan but still forgot anything that's not
in that color spectrum and so we've just
got that sort of afternoon
shape that's appearing there and so in
order to turn that into some coordinates
or some a flight plan that we can
actually follow using a really simple
algorithm that just computes the center
of mass of the image so in this case
that means looking at all those parts of
the image that are red and then
calculating what the middle of that
image is so it's actually conceptually
quite simple and which is somewhat nice
or something that's kind of complex and
what you'll see is when you do that I
place the dot just where that is
actually right smack down in the middle
red so it works pretty well it's not too
complicated and it's pretty fast to
actually turn that into some coordinates
that we can that we can use to direct
the drone is actually fairly easy I'm
way to do that I'm computing the kind of
the center as a percentage so I'm
creating a vector that's going to point
from the center of the image to the spot
on the image to the spot where the red
part is showing up so pretty simple get
my x and y coordinates I'll grab that
image again I'm gonna put a vector or a
line on that image and when it shows
back up you can see I've got that nice
vector that's pointing from the middle
to the drip to the red part yeah yeah
that's a great that's a really good
question so keep on and this has
happened incidentally when people in the
office are wearing a red shirt so if for
instance a head something right here and
something right over here the algorithm
would compute it in such a way that you
would determine the middle or the
direction
in the center so it is susceptible to
certain flaws there are ways to get
around that use a really weird color red
is actually not super common in offices
another one is if you it would be
slightly different but you could train
the algorithm to look for a particular
shape or look for a particular object so
for instance we actually played around
with instead of using something red with
using a piece of paper with a smiley
face on it which is actually that's
pretty unique it's not hard every we're
on a time crunch so we stuck with red
but there are other ways you could kind
of go about it and in Turpan order to
create uniqueness so from that just
really quick here from that from that
placement we'll wind up with is I had
the dustbin relatively in the middle so
really enough to know where to go in the
x direction in the Y direction it was
above the center of the camera so my
algorithm said okay you should go
28% thrust downwards so it works pretty
well you can actually put it to the test
now alright so with that we can get down
business all right
one second here let me get everything
ready
all right cool
another thing I found always have an
emergency landing script handy before
you start this type of stuff just in
case
all right right all right more or less
where's my mouse
you you can go to maybe there we go what
if I point at you does it still dad so
funny
oops
Oh
sorry
is this job supposed to be about
distance know nothing about distance
yeah just trying to get to follow it
left or right
mm-hmm yep so I'm using a I'm using a
nodejs library that's right now this the
best one is available for the drone
that's set up as just a server that can
talk to the drone and then I have a
Python client that's pinging that so
it's a little bit of a roundabout way of
accessing and talking the drone but it
it does work so I have just you know
import drone and then I can run various
commands Word
all right calm trip will do one more
trial it might be out of battery
there yeah
you know going for the
Wow
all right well thank you I unfortunately
get the best run but Hoku's at least fun
and give questions I have plenty time to
talk about anything else
so the question was how fast can attract
the movement or the object the biggest
limiting factor that I've found and this
was something that was driving me crazy
until three days ago was that the it
takes a while for the image to get from
the realm to the Python process the
Python process there is computing the
color and the faces is actually pretty
fast so overcome that time I had to drop
down the quality of the image so that's
what when you see any probably notices
it was a little grainy pixelation was
was pretty high so it's it'd be nicer if
it was faster but it's using this
library called FF then and that's where
the choke points
just kind of fun and makes it a little
bit out a little bit a little bit more
fun yeah you can avoid hitting somebody
maybe going the opposite direction of
faces but unfortunately though the
graininess is it makes it harder if
you're trying to do it like in real time
once yes I haven't put it on getting up
but I will it's mine it's kind of a all
over the place right now
you'll find it under get it out / y hat
/ drone drone yeah yeah
yes there Oh from static images I don't
from static I don't from static images
there's a module that someone built for
the drone that can do like instead of
just using like arbitrary you know go
right at 10% or 20% thrust you can do
distances you can say go forward 10
meters or go right 10 meters so that
part that would be kind of half of it
and the other half was the actual image
stuff and when I was figuring out what
what I was gonna use for this I did come
across something I think it was in the
Google just released a really cool
algorithm that'll do they'll like look
at a room and figure out the different
parts of the room and get like spatial
kind of stuff so I can't remember the
name of it anyone knows it yeah try that
have you thought about
they sent this command
I forgot enough art I wish the so if you
can't tell from the back there's a
little bit of duct tape and whatnot on
the trim and it's been through a lot so
I think the whole like going back thing
function of that
five example
yes I haven't threatened then you can
you can SSH sorry the question was
rather trying with a Raspberry Pi or
hardened you know like that guy thing
I I have not I decided like one really
new toy per project these super this you
can SSH into the drone and it's runs
Linux some flavor I don't know I don't
know what but you can monkey around the
bit and it's it's running over Wi-Fi so
it's it's actually really easy to set up
the network and all that like right now
I'm just connected to the drone it's
like a our drone and then some serial
number it was really easy to program I
was shocked I thought it would take me
like a week to figure out how to get it
to work with Python with no js' and it
worked the first time which almost never
happens
now I didn't get in I didn't get that
far
they're piping it over Wi-Fi
loot if I even know I didn't try
the sensors can measure grab the example
actually
I don't have it you can get the altitude
good things about it there is a plugin
that can do GPS you have to find there's
a lot of information about the position
of it so angle I was an aerospace
engineer so I'm gonna block all these
terms
no I don't like an ultrasonic sensor
that's an accelerometer I know yeah
we use cases for aside the image
they do overlap it's honestly they all
seem to do kind of the same thing Sai
kit images API tends to work it does
it's more more like modern Python
canisters I can't learn then OpenCV
looks more like someone took a C++
librarian just converting the Python so
it works totally fine
but for me I'm comfortable of Python
them so it's a lot easier to use this
image this was great well thanks guys I
think you'll be great